the history of mankind has been a long
and bloody struggle between nations
groups and individuals always trying to
claim a bit more land to call their own
other people have usually been around to
try to stop these invaders but what
happens when the territory in question
isn't on earth if this is your first
time visiting the channel make sure to
subscribe and click the little bell to
be notified every time a new second
thought video is released back in 1967
the governments of the United States the
UK and the Soviet Union thought it might
be a good idea to agree to some ground
rules for the use of outer space the
Outer Space Treaty now agreed upon by
over a hundred nations prohibits any
country from placing nuclear weapons in
outer space or on any celestial body it
also explicitly forbids any nation from
claiming a space resource such as the
moon or a planet and so far it's worked
out to date no government has attempted
to claim a celestial body but what if
that were to change let's say North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un got it into
his head that he wanted to own the moon
and somehow managed to launch a manned
mission and successfully land North
Koreans on the moon they plant the flag
and a little statue of the glorious
leader and hunker down to defend their
new prize from all invaders now what
realistically Kim jong-un would likely
get a stern talking-to by the other
members of the treaty and suffer even
more sanctions here on earth and the
incident would be forgotten if however
the North Koreans managed to construct
some form of delivery system for nuclear
warheads on the moon the global response
would probably be far more severe but
what if an individual tried to claim a
celestial body while the outer space
treaty does say non government entities
will require authorization to operate in
outer space and are the responsibility
of their parent nation it does not
explicitly state that an individual
cannot claim a planet or moon with the
recent success of the SpaceX Falcon
Heavy rocket we need to consider the
possibility that Elon Musk could go full
supervillain and claim Mars as his own
but how would that work exactly what
does it take to legally own something
the size of Mars the doctrine of first
possession basically the legal
equivalent of Finders Keepers states
that in order to claim something you
must first show intention and control
and possession goes into effect as soon
as those two criteria are met
simply planting a spacex flag on the red
planet is enough to show the intent of
ownership but how do you control the
whole
the easiest way would probably be to
build simple roads and tiny outposts
over much of the planet surface once a
road is built you could reasonably claim
a certain amount of territory on either
side of it enough roads and you've
secured the whole planet of course the
idea of first possession is not
universally agreed upon so this claim
would be iffy at best
back on earth American authorities would
likely step in and demand the claim be
redacted
if Ilan refused further actions would be
taken if the members of the treaty
considered his claim to be a threat to
the earth the only way to ensure
complete ownership of Mars would be to
do it all at once you'd have to send
enough manpower materials and supplies
to establish a self-sufficient colony
and leave the earth behind entirely if
you could do that the only way to get
you to renounce your claim would be for
other nations to physically come to Mars
and force you if Elan musk did decide to
establish himself as emperor of Mars the
nations of Earth would have quite the
predicament on their hands there
currently aren't any space agencies
prepared to send a manned mission to the
red planet which would give a lot more
time to build his empire and by the time
NASA or the ESA arrived the Mars colony
might have a 10 or 20 year head start
and it might not even be safe to land on
the surface if the Martian citizens are
hostile against earthling invaders of
course this is all wild speculation odds
are Elon Musk won't go crazy and
establish a Galactic Empire off earth
but the fact remains that as successes
of private groups and governments begin
to snowball and space becomes more
accessible rules and regulations
governing ownership of space will need
to change will earth law even apply to
eventual space colonies or will
regulations vary by celestial body what
do you think will we end up with a new
Wild West out in space or will the
governments of the world work together
to make space exploration a free and
peaceful experience let us know your
thoughts in the comments below if you
enjoyed this episode make sure to
subscribe and click the little Bell to
join the notification squad to watch
more content like this video check out
these playlists I've also just added a
new reward for my patreon supporters so
if you want to get a behind-the-scenes
look at second thought and support the
channel check out our patreon page
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next week